les jeunes haut-rhinois ont de la chance
tous les ans ils sont des milliers à
pouvoir rencontrer des joueurs sportifs
de haut niveau grâce aux mercredis
sportifs exemple à kingersheim avec les
joueuses de l' as ptt mulhouse volley un
entraînement hors du commun des enfants
de clubs de volley-ball locaux au côté
dispose professionnels de l' esprit tu
étais mulhouse
la différence est de taille au sens
propre comme au figuré
alors les enfants ont des étoiles plein
les yeux elle salue jouer
elles sont grandes et elle songeait
n'diaye
de quoi motiver les jeunes pousses c'est
ça l'objectif des mercredis du sport les
meilleurs joueurs du département au
contact des plus jeunes
il faut que ton papa de marque prévoit
bien la sphère exercice et conseils de
trop il n'y a pas photo ça change de
l'ordinaire m'aide à la fin surtout qu'
il y aura de bons quoi çà et là c'est
quand même déjà alors que les
entraîneurs c'est quand même pas avant
là ça c'est pas sympa pour leur
entraîneur mais bon c'est vrai qu'elle
donne envie les joueuses de l'as ptt
mulhouse et en plus les enfants
elle adore moi j'aime personnellement
après peut-être qu'avec elle il faut
beaucoup de patience je travaille avec
les petites mais moi je pense aux
classiques sont pleins d'entrain ya
beaucoup de joie il ya énormément de
partage a fait du bien on apprécie mais
on reste trop aller encore 50 poupe
avant de passer aux abdos